a special session of the state
legislature is officially underway in
carson city the governor called state
lawmakers to go over redistricting maps
that were revealed earlier this week it
is done every 10 years joe mohler joins
us in the studio with what exactly
happened joe o'brien lawmakers gathered
for a few hours this afternoon and
created committees that will discuss the
proposed new maps they will have to
create new boundaries with roughly the
same number of people in each one
every 10 years the population is counted
in the census nevada added 400 thousand
people over the past decade that means
political districts need to be redrawn
to accommodate population changes that's
what this redistricting is going to do
it's setting the rules unlv political
expert dan lee says the state has seen a
lot of changes the matter has been on
this trend over the past really 20 years
of becoming more racially diverse
lawmakers will look at boundaries for
state senate and assembly congressional
districts and board of regents lee
explained how this could impact the
congressional districts because
democrats are you know they currently
have a three to one advantage and
they're going to try to
shore up that advantage so they're going
to try to redraw the districts
that probably makes the third district
for instance a little bit safer
democrats control the legislature and
governor's office republicans would have
to file legal challenges to fight any
changes currently we have
38 percent of our people are
non-partisans
34 percent are democrats and about 30
percent are republicans state assembly
woman robin titus says she isn't happy
with the proposed maps these maps that
the democrats have submitted
all it does is secure that the democrats
will stay in a super majority for the
next decade subcommittees will have to
do three readings of the maps on three
different days before a vote can happen
we did reach out to democrat officials
for comment but we did not hear back
today lawmakers will reconvene tomorrow
morning reporting in the studio joe
muller live local now